or isabelle la dernière semaine a été
difficile le congé forcé de ses trois
enfants les sous et certains gars ventre
aux enfants puis avoir à continuer à
travailler puis en plus porter le
chapeau de professeurs c'est pas
nécessairement ce qui est le plus
enthousiasmant mais en même temps on va
faire ce qu'il faut on n'a pas le choix
isabelle n'est pas au bout de ses peines
le gouvernement du québec prolonge la
fermeture des écoles pour encore
plusieurs semaines
tous ces établissements vont être
fermées jusqu'au 1er mai d'ici là le
gouvernement du québec va aider les
parents il va mettre en ligne des
activités pour les jeunes
il va aussi envoyer des listes de
travaux qui pourront être faits par les
élèves à la maison pour aider les jeunes
à continuer s'obtient l'apprentissage
des mesures qui vont t'aider isabelle
gendron la semaine dernière j'ai vérifié
plusieurs références qu'on m'a envoyé
soi de l'école sur des groupes facebook
puis je voudrais bien franchement que
j'étais un petit peu en panique c'était
difficile pour moi de faire faire les
bonnes choses à mes enfants
charlotte et billetterie sont bien
contents que le gouvernement du québec
donne un coup de pouce à leurs parents
ils m'ont mis la preuve qu'on est crade
et des cours de maths et le français
toutes les matières caisse c'est ça j'ai
trouvé ce crime parce que je prends pas
m'ennuyer puis ou même en mai après
travail et kaka voudra mais la mère de
famille ne cache pas qu'elle est
inquiète que la tâche sera lourde pour
elle c'est inquiétant de savoir que
c'est un les parents qui vont devoir
faire les apprentissages montrer les
apprentissages aux enfants puis deux
ballons vient de perdre le séjour
d'école le syndicat qui représente les
enseignants voient d'un bon oeil ce qui
a été annoncé aujourd'hui
on veut travailler avec le ministère on
veut travailler avec le ministre et on
est totalement disponible pour le faire
isabelle et ses enfants espère que le
gouvernement du québec ne fera pas comme
l'alberta émettre afin éventuellement
l'année scolaire et ces gens si les pros
bien en radio canada montréal